did you ever call brian and say
you know i did it i took your advice
you know i didn't isn't that terrible no
ryan and i really did drifted apart i
learned
so much from him on stage and i also
learned from him offstage like that
example
but he could be so difficult to live
with
um that we didn't really get along so
we had some famous fights on stage
actually during the performance
like almost these these subtle moments
that only you and he knew about
oh no oh no like
what like the opening at the kennedy
center
which is a state event because it's part
of the you know it's a national monument
the kennedy center
so people are there like black tie and
stuff right and
brian could be such a prac on stage
he was such a diva and death trap is
about these
two writers who are sort of dueling with
each other and they're
there's many many layers to the play i
don't want to get into it now it's hard
to describe
but there are points where one one
writer finds what the other writer has
been writing
and reads it aloud so you're basically
reading
a lot of exposition that the audience
has already seen
because it's like a play within a play
within a play so it's very difficult to
keep
the audience's interest because they've
already seen all this stuff
and i had the first one of these
speeches
and during it brian
became just riveted by something
on the rug and he started going down on
his all fours on the rug
trying to find something and the
audience knew exactly what he was doing
and they started laughing
laughing he was just stealing focus
and he was just being ruthless about it
and totally ignoring me
and i got louder and louder it was
driving me crazy
and then i i calmed down and then his
turn
came in the next scene to do the same
thing
to have to read an expository don't tell
me you got on the floor
no i turned around and there was a
bookcase behind me
and i started looking for books in the
bookcase and i was taking it out and
look at him i just couldn't look i
couldn't find what i wanted
and he was getting louder and louder and
more strident
trying to get my attention and i was
ignoring him and the audience knew
exactly what i was doing and they were
howling that i was giving him back
exactly what he'd given me
and just at that moment i was turning
back to him
and he was getting ready to swat me in
the head with the script
you know we've found a script that each
of us is working on
so just as i'm turning this script comes
and bashes me in the face
and the rivet from the script grazes my
eye and i thought he had
really hurt me and i went crazy and
we're behi
on either side of this big lawyer's
partner desk
and i lunged for him and he
threw down the script and he lunged for
me and we heard murray giblin the stage
manager from the wing and say
gentlemen gentlemen please this is the
theater
[Laughter]
on stage
oh my god we need to just sit back in
our chairs
and we were doing all of this through
the lines of the play we never stopped
saying the lines of the play
so the whole thing you know we're doing
this play and we're like i want to
kill you and that was the subtext was i
want to kill you
and then we both sit down and we got
through the scene and the
playwright ireland who also wrote
rosemary's baby and big playwright
had come down from new york with his
family
for the kennedy center opening and he
was in the audience
and he loved it no this is i thought i
am so
fired i am never going to work in the
theater again this is my first big job
after juilliard this is my first big
break
i'm out i'm out they're gonna blackball
me he comes to my dressing room and he
says
you were brilliant it was incredible it
was like watching hamlet where did you
find all that in my play
so you guys they thought it was part of
it yeah we kept saying the lines
we were just playing it this this
hostile
anger fury at each other but we've never
stu broken out a cat
and what did you did he say anything
afterwards like i'm sorry no brian
didn't know how to say i'm sorry
you know i think if you probably if you
notice any similarities in someone that
your your father might have had or
drinking or things are there certain
things triggers that you're like
can't be around that person that's
something that's just that's that's
too much for me that's i can't deal with
that
selfishness to the point of narcissism i
find
impossible to be around
you